no went welcome to this video playing
ESO call mr. circling I am at 1 a minus
squad didn't I have a an equal score
widely used against him after catching
up quite a bit weird anyway let's see
what he does goes for this cell this is
similar one to Magnus Carlsen it on the
point against Levon Aronian in the
norway chest in Norway chess council was
make sure you granting a temple to
Iranian ok what's this don't get it what
I can take here and what's the deal and
of course you decided that in a split
second came across it's so easy yeah so
what's the deal yeah maybe you can look
the 81 what's the deal i have 95 ok ok
ok so i can do various things i can also
um play would be one will be one Queen D
tree and the main problem is as it Oasis
against this kind play some some
nonsense and then I'm losing on time so
let's be quick him this is one of the
lines that should be a bit better than
me I just didn't look for the best one I
just go when for one line you can get
you three now it doesn't um I didn't it
take I don't understand I don't
understand anything here ok so he won or
can I do something better to know
probably not three
comparing d3 now so I just keep the the
pawn let's just control everything a
file a4 a5 and so on can also do this
maybe c5 okay let's just drag queen seon
let's go no nonsense I have a very very
nice target on 37 just have to be
cautious and if i move the night for
example there's all kinds of tricks am
like 93 Bishop d3 this kind of stops
right right up his alley pain but where
let's do this and go Knight to c3 I want
to have nice night a form as a potential
thing when I deform so what's going on
here 95 okay i 94 and so I can do nine
to be 6 or 9 p-6 I would have two pawns
I can take it takes eight at the end and
win both plants but he will win 8 5
which is not
that great anyway
yeah wonder how I how I get those pawns
to move I can actually this is not a big
deal if you check me on d4 here even
with you for in doesn't really that
doesn't really matter all that much
clock yeah yeah 93-92 was pretty strong
it doesn't matter have your tanks I
don't mind if he takes this correct okay
now i can take this and take this so he
wants to check me there okay if I go up
I notice you can actually take so let's
go b6 check check check check I have two
ropes black resigns yeah sorry for the
commentary in a way we can have a
history of losing completely winning
positions against them so I kind of it's
kind of a grudge match because it tends
to play in this way like every game and
still wins because I'm losing on time
we'll do something stupid anyway so that
was a really strange opening here coming
to be six and then taking here like in a
split second okay so i took this okay
let's switch on the analysis i keep on
forgetting that I have this now so 93
yearbook 28 and now it's keep it simple
it's also what the computer wants to do
not want to take with a pawn
no I didn't have this on the radar and
i'm also not totally convinced this okay
okay it is very good yeah he has given
up his strong bishop the king is weak I
felt that this is also just good gives
me a great piece on the fire look this
happen I was thinking my didn t take him
that was my idea is a better ending for
white and he has very little in terms of
utility but it still looks better than
rooty 747 just looks like it's lost in
this position i think is objectively
losing young which is basically
confirmed by the computer okay queen bee
fire was better but I was just trying to
be somewhat quick and not not get into
something crazy at the end because as I
said I lost a lot against him in those
situations yeah after 6i think it should
be over really and that it's um yeah
okay hmm i'd answer the phone about it
9a seven is this situation we're winning
another winning more material and like
this i can actually take with the bishop
oh i didn't didn't ever think of that
yeah okay this is probably winning if i
can take this without trading of
everything i mean i'm free porns up then
it just opposite colored bishops and i
mean if i get a six I mean those
training down and I have those two extra
parts in an ending just with bishops I'm
not totally sure that I would win but
okay I was thinking just everything as
is
and then I don't think it's bad I mean
the engine is just giving me the solid
plus try every time the whole time so
yeah I'm ready to trade this Bishop now
and then things should fall apart him
check check check clapping yeah they do
yeah maybe with the game there was a
first win of the session playing six
games and scoring basically nothing so
at least getting one when one winning ok
guys thanks for watching